hello everyone
thank you for coming in this afternoon
my name is eric gady and
today i'm going to be talking about
what authorship means when we think
about computing as a medium for thought
and
how we can find the personal in personal
computing when we do so
so let's jump right in
what is it that's personal
about personal computing
is it because you own it
it's not a time shared system
you have it on your lap or your desktop
or in your pocket
or is it because you can customize it
you can put different fonts you can put
a sticker on your laptop you can change
your background if you want
or on the other hand is it because the
person
is what is actually the raw material in
a surveillance economy
that is people's minds that are being
harvested
now all of this is true all of this are
is
our reasons that personal computing is
personal but if you're like me you
intuit that there is something else to
that that there is something that has to
do with the interaction between a
personal computer and some kind of
augmentation of your own mind
now uh this wouldn't be
a tech
talk unless somebody invoked the prophet
steve jobs so i'll be the martyr
and i will play a clip of steve talking
about this very issue
i think one of the the things that
really separates us from the high
primates is that uh we're tool builders
and i read a uh
a study that measured the efficiency of
locomotion
for various species on the planet
the condor used the least energy to move
a kilometer
and uh humans came in uh with a rather
unimpressive showing about a third of
the way down the list it was not
not too proud of a showing for the crown
of creation
so uh
that didn't look so good but then
somebody at scientific american had the
insight to test the efficiency of
locomotion for a man on a bicycle
and a man on a bicycle or a human on a
bicycle blew the condor away completely
off the top of the charts
and that's what a computer is to me uh
what a computer is to me is it's the
most remarkable tool that we've ever
come up with and it's the equivalent of
a bicycle for our minds
so
this is the famous bicycle for the mind
analogy
and
this is really good marketing because at
first at first blush this sounds like
it's saying something significant
but if you dig into it a little bit more
you run into some interesting problems
so here the analogy has he's making is
between energy efficiency what is energy
efficient about your mind from the
computer is that what he's talking about
probably not
is he talking about thinking more
efficiency efficiently is thinking more
efficiently thinking better if you had a
thought in the shower you probably think
probably not
um
so what i interpret from this is
something that's even a little shallower
than that and that he's simply paying
reference to this general cultural value
of efficiency as a good for its own sake
and that kind of comes from more
contemporary economic thinking
throughout society
and it's associated with productivity
specifically
industrial kinds of productivity
and that is a lot of what computing has
become to be associated with
there's this idea that computing
is a new kind of industrial revolution
for the mind
um
i think that this is a bad analogy
it's bad because first of all it's not
borne out in the economics
the productivity part and second because
it doesn't lead us anywhere it only gets
us to today
so
if we toss this aside what are we left
with
we have some nebulous concept of
intelligence augmentation
well
there is another technology that we can
make an analogy to it's one that is old
very well attested
uh and has had massive civilization
changing effects it's one that we all
interact with on a daily basis without
even really realizing it most of the
time
that's reading and writing literacy
and taking this perspective is not
something i'm thinking of originally a
lot of the pioneers of personal
computing 40 and 50 years ago were
thinking very deeply about a literacy
analogy when it came to the medium
but i want to
be plain about what i'm suggesting from
here on out and that is that i think
that we have a lot to gain
by using an analogy of literacy
to say that computing as a medium can
give us new intellectual capabilities
the same way literacy did before it
so let's dig into this literacy analogy
have a look at this slide
now
i can't say
what you were thinking when you read
this
but i can say with reasonable certainty
what you weren't thinking
you were not looking at each of these
glyphs and decoding it into its english
phoneme its sound in the language you
weren't even sounding out words i'm
willing to bet you weren't thinking
about grammar or syntax or even where
that line broke
right what you were doing was thinking
up here
you were in this mental space purely of
ideas
right
and you don't remember it but it took
you a lot of work to get there
so you broke through a threshold of
literacy and once you did that there was
no going back
and this is really significant this is
the big idea of literacy that there's a
new mental space in which you can
interrogate your own ideas
so
there's a cycle to this that makes it
important right you think of something
you can write it down
you can read it this is saint augustine
notably reading quietly very personal
activity uncommon in his time just like
you guys i didn't hear a lot of sound
when you were reading that last slide
okay so what do we get from all this
well it turns out it's the basis for
everything philosophy science
mathematics everything is built upon
this foundation it is impossible to
think of it if you have not broken
through that threshold
it is a new kind of thought
entirely
now i'm going to take a different angle
looking at this analogy and talk about
the origins of writing
so writing appears
independently in at least three places
that we know about but i'm going to look
at the oldest so the oldest writing
system comes from ancient sumer which is
in modern day iraq
it's called cuneiform which means wedge
shaped and it involves taking a stylus
and pressing it into clay tablets to
make shapes
so the earliest attest did genea
cuneiform comes from about 3200 bce
for those of you who aren't savvy with
the history that's over 5000 years ago
and the form here is one of basic
accounting so there's not really words
here it's more pictographic
and there are things like heads and jugs
and then dots and that's saying how many
jugs of beer do these heads get for
working because you got paid in beer
which was nice
so let's fast forward a thousand years
or more and with old babylonian period
aha things have gotten more interesting
the writing system is more comprehensive
in this
script
there is a
horrible mixture
of syllablegrams that is
signs that have a sound value
pictograms like in the original
proto-cuneiform and then ideograms which
are symbols that actually do mean a
particular word in a language
and they are used in a highly ambiguous
way
right this is a very complicated writing
system but now it's spreading everywhere
that is a stella of the laws of
hamarappi so that's how far you know
that they're getting with this
and then in the most contemporary period
we'll look at we have the neo-assyrian
and so by 600 bc what's happened
is some of these forms have simplified
but the core of the writing system is
still just this complicated jumble mess
it's still
syllablegrams and ideograms and
logograms all mixed together ambiguously
what's most important is that throughout
this entire period
as writing is spreading everywhere
it is almost
the exclusive purview of a class of
people called scribes
they have near total domain over this
knowledge
okay so why am i bringing any of this up
the amount of time between that first
tablet and that last tablet is 2500
years
whole cities and cultures and empires
rise and fall during that time period a
lot happens
but the basics after a certain point
don't change
things are still complicated all right
well then how do we get here how do we
get to mass literacy there's a bunch of
things you need
the book's a good idea
why don't we have a codex why don't we
have pages so we can hold more writing
we can index the pages it's portable
uh
why don't we slap this on it
this will give us a standardized way of
reading and more importantly it'll be
able to mass produce identical texts for
everybody
and even more importantly not to be
underestimated is a much simpler writing
system
here i'm using the alphabet just as an
example there are other simpler writing
systems in the world like the korean
but yeah let's take 20 something glyphs
attach them to sounds that's all anybody
needs to know
and then by far the most important
factor
you have an institutional and social
commitment
to having everyone in your society break
through that threshold and once you do
that you have a literate society
now i think that we don't have anything
like mass literacy and computing today
not even close
i would argue that
most of us at this conference myself
included we are the scribes we are an
ascribable computing culture
so as my examples here i have the guys
inventing unix
on the pdp their primary input and
output there is a teletype that's a
close-up of a teletype command line
output that's about 1972.
50 years later there's my terminal
emulator
and the forms have gotten a little
simpler i got color and stuff
but what is it emulating it's emulating
that teletype
and
what's worse
it's running a unix
so
why am i bringing this up a lot happens
in the world in 50 years right a lot has
happened in computing it's spread all
over the place just like writing spread
all over the place in the cuneiform era
but the form hasn't really changed that
much
it is conducive to a scribal culture
and computing's also describable an even
more important way and that's that there
is a strong and i think
uh
completely unnecessary bifurcation
between programmers and users
so in that sense we
make these systems as black boxes we
give them to people and then they can
interpret them as magic
they can make of them whatever they want
because they don't even have the tools
to understand what this is and that is
because we don't give them the medium to
do so
so you might think
okay whatever you know our computer is
really powerful i'll turbo charge this
thing to like 4.8 gigahertz do some
machine learning this will all be great
but the problem is
uh we aren't thinking the new
as einstein said we cannot solve
problems with the same thinking that
produce them
uh the key to doing this is to have
thinking using the computing medium
become more personalized
so if we look at what happens with math
for example
you know you needed writing and literacy
conventional literacy to
they were sufficient but not enough to
bring about a mathematical language that
we have today
and um
the thing about this is that computing
is not
a new language in an older medium it's a
new medium itself so if we're going to
do a new kind of mathematics
we need some kind of
new system for doing so we don't want to
uh be running math in our teletype
environments
so
you know we need new ways to represent
these things right
and then to think about them
and then
we're on our way to the future
so
where does all this get us i think the
best thing to do is to condense the
actual question that we have into the
simplest possible phrasing and the one i
like the best comes from andy decessa in
the opening paragraph of his book
changing minds and he asks can computers
convey to humans a new increment of
intellectual power that rivals what
conventional literacy has given us
that's the core question
so
what does that mean for personal
authorship
well
i'm sorry but i can't give you a
definition of authorship but what i can
say
is that it is the exploration in this
context of the following two questions
what does it mean to read in the media
medium of computing and what does it
mean to write in the medium of computing
and are those in the same thing or not
so i want to look at some historical
examples here of what we think was going
in a good direction for authorship and
the first system i want to highlight is
hypercard
so hypercard was created at apple oops
hypercode was created at apple by bill
atkinson in 1987
and what it was is a kind of software
erector set where you got
uh
a bunch of different pieces objects like
buttons and fields and things and they
would go on the central metaphor
that was used here which was stacks and
cards so an application in the hyper
card sense was a stack stack of cards
each card was a view you could put
buttons on it fields images paint and it
fit very cleanly into the mac operating
system at the time
all of those objects could be opened up
and inspected
you could see how they worked on the
inside
by doing a special kind of click
and under that click was a scripting
language that was highly readable called
hypertalk
hypertalk was
written to be kind of like natural
english
but the most important aspect of it from
our point of view is that it was easier
to read than it was to write
to us that's essential for exploration
uh for people coming in from the outside
they don't need to know everything they
just need to maybe understand how one
thing works
hypercard also shipped free with every
macintosh for years
uh to the point where
by the mid 90s we have conflicting
numbers about this from people we've
spoken with but there's something
somewhere between four and six million
stack authors i think that's remarkable
particularly if you
if any of you were around at the time
know how many people were actually mac
owners in the early 90s
the other system i want to point to is
small talk
so for those who don't know small talk
is a pure object-oriented language and
environment
in one
this was
the legendary system that was developed
at the xerox park learning research
group starting in 1982 this is the group
that was headed by
alan kaye
and
the central metaphor here
is that you only have these elementary
computing objects and the only thing
that happens in a system is that they
send or receive messages
your job is to configure the system to
send certain messages you can define how
objects
behave when they get the message
it had all these things we like today
live debugging you program it while it
runs
and much like hyper card everything can
be popped open and inspected on a whim
uh
it had very importantly because it was
an environment and a language had a
minimal set of linguistic concepts
minimal syntax because most everything
that happened occurred in this
environment
and i think this is probably the most
important aspect of this the system was
designed and experimented initially on
children
so what was happening here was that this
team knew that personal computing was
going to go out into the world
they thought in about five to ten years
and they said that they wanted to
explore what the mode of interaction
would be like they did not have in mind
a strict separation between users and
programmers so they wanted to know
what's the easiest way that we can get
people to actually do computing
and that's why they started with
children but they always said children
of all ages because they figured the
systems that went out into the world
would eventually be just as applicable
to
uh adults
and
diana mary who was one of the
programmers
on the small talk system when we spoke
to her said mentioned to us rather
interestingly that
in that group marshall mcluhan was
required reading
so they were very steeped in this this
sort of media criticism and literary
studies uh when they came up with these
systems
so what are the main takeaways
from these examples
this is a big one for us
we don't care so much about languages if
you consider them independently of the
environments in which they operate and
in which people use them
but from our perspective the most
important concept might be in computing
might be the use of metaphor
if you have good metaphors
you're going to have a system that is
very rich
and highly usable and conducive to being
manipulated by all kinds of people
and then there's a third aspect here
which is what adele goldberg who was a
member of the that research group at
xerox park
calls the onion
she literally wrote the book on small
talk by the way she's the author
and what she means here in this quote is
that when you are using a system and you
get to a point where you need to do
something that you just quite can't do
at this layer you should be able to just
peel back a little bit and see one layer
down about how it's working and what's
going on
you should be able as you use a system
that is yours that is personal
continuously peel back layers all the
way down
so last year i was a very fortunate
position to work with two long time
collaborators in a
lab environment
and
we were basically told we could work on
whatever we wanted so we wanted to pull
from these
this literacy analogy
and
discuss how we would design our
basically our ideal computing system
from the ground up what might be
involved
what are the big uh
what's like the framework we would use
uh and so to start with we thought these
two ideas are great the onion idea and
the metaphor idea are great and maybe we
can combine them
and early on what we came up with was
this very vague sketch
of what the system would be like but i
think it's important so i'm going to
explain it to you a little bit here
you can have layers of metaphor so you
can have different layers that are
themselves a consistent metaphor
universal metaphor
that can then be used to describe the
next layer above it
so at the bottom here
we had this idea of uh actors and not
just in the carl hewitt sense but the
entire hardware would be abstracted by
uh stage play
metaphor so you know
stage manager takes care of your memory
the director runs instructions on a core
and that could be used to describe some
kind of ui metaphor that we
were going to describe and then you
could go to something that's hyper card
like above that right stacks and cards
and then eventually you get to your
desktop environment and what that means
of course is when the entry point for
someone buying a computer or using one
is that desktop environment now they can
peel down
oh how does my desktop how does the
close button in my finder work well just
peel down and it looks like it's some
hypercard like stack thing or something
go down all the way to the bottom if you
want to
uh
as with research projects we figured we
probably only had three to six months
funding
so what could we
what's the biggest piece we could uh
chew here and we decided to go for this
layer
and what we ended up creating
uh is a system that we very cleverly
call simple talk
and it is a web-based system for now
and uh
there's a couple caveats here it's it's
it's experimental
and we don't think i'm not saying in any
way that this is the solution to all the
problems i was highlighting earlier this
is just one attempt at exploring the
ideas
so i'm going to describe a little bit of
about that to you now
um
some of you
might have guessed
uh this you've been in simple talk the
whole time so this presentation is in
the browser this is a simple talk world
as we call it
and there's uh there's my presentation
stack and all my cards down here in this
navigator
um
and so we use this spatial metaphor we
thought it's a good one cards and stacks
is really intuitive
and the simple talk system is made up of
what we call parts
these are active uh dynamic entities
that are the core of the system they're
sort of a vocabulary of things that you
use when constructing things in the
system and the other spatial metaphors
that we have in these parts is we have
windows and we have these generic areas
for containing
other parts
and of course we have parts for doing
things the most exciting kind
audio images drawings
video
text fields and of course buttons
and
just like in hypercard or in small talk
you can pop open this button and you can
see the script
that
runs that you can change it if you want
so
these are
live objects that people are familiar
with it is a lexicon that people already
know and that's what one aspect that we
thought was very important about it
sorry my mouse isn't working okay
and we also have the metaphor of
communication that's message
sending and passing
all of the parts communicate by sending
and receiving messages when you script
in our scripting language you are simply
describing what happens when a certain
message is received
now importantly all of our parts have
what we call properties they are
reactive
aspects of each object
that
that you can change using scripting and
that can be changed as a result of
sending messages
so
for example here i have an audio and i
can play it and what will happen is the
property change message will
automatically be sent and if there's
something there
on my button
it will change the play state and you
can see that this audio changes the
button activation state as well this is
simple
communication of
properties and messages between these
parts the other thing is that we think
this is fairly readable as well
and as you can tell
for those of you who know it is
inspired by hypertalk
and the final thing is that there is
nothing sacred here
everything in the system is made up of
these parts
so the editor you saw with the script in
it it's just a field with a button and a
window there's nothing special about it
it sends a message to the system when
you're compiling a script we can
save a script here now this button will
say hello
and if you know i can change the save
button so that it makes this the object
that it's targeting do a spin or
whatever i want it's a silly example but
and you can also change the editor
itself you can have it flash when you
type right because it's simply just
changing these properties under the hood
every time a new character is put in
and the key concept here is that there's
a special property
that's called the target
so any part can have another
a reference to another part as its
target property and that's what's
happening here when we compile this
script we're saying take what's in this
field
make it the script of that button and
while you're at it spin it around
so
that's a summary of the basics of this
simple talk system and and
how we've been using the onion and the
central concept of metaphor so we have
our world stacks and cards
our communication metaphor uses what we
think are these clear relationships
messaging natural language in this case
which is readable
we use the
current vocabulary of computing that
everybody knows buttons browsers fields
and
it's the beginning of this onion peeling
process
so
i'm just going to wrap up here and in
doing so i want to say
that
the shallow analogies
have real corrosive
uh effects in the world real
consequences
and we think that bad metaphors can lead
us astray
i don't think it's a coincidence that
when the thinking about personal
computing switched from being about
books to being about bicycles
that we saw a seemingly endless amount
of
energy
and resources
intelligence and imagination being
poured into
environments of highly dubious social
value
and i think we need to take this
authorship idea seriously and if we are
going to be serious about it and
recognize our scribal position
right we need to
build systems that people can change in
the sense of authorship
and not just systems that change people
uh
and so if you are interested in
learning more about simple talk we have
a
home stack running at this site
along with um a description of the parts
and and and utilities like that there's
the
uh repository link
these are my collaborators special thank
you to uh daniel krasner and thomas
nyberg
and
i have time for questions if anyone has
any thank you
[Applause]
yeah so let me see if i can summarize
the question for the stream
uh
is are there is there is there enough of
a ratio of people who are just content
consumers rather than content creators
to
justify building these kind of
authorships is that a fair description
um
i'll give you an example that we use
frequently
uh
in the mac operating system today
uh any user goes and they know what a
button is
they're
all over the place what do you do with
the button you click it now time to make
a button
there is nothing in between for them the
only thing you can do is download swift
and xcode and learn a full programming
language
there's nothing in
between
there's a second part of my answer to
your question which is that we set the
culture if people
don't feel like they want to do
something maybe it's because they don't
even know that's possible
and there let me go back here they're
the people in this slide
right they don't know what's popped they
don't know anything about this
we're not helping them
so i do think that there is space for it
i think that those early examples are
really attest to the fact that there is
it's just that something got off the
rails here
right there were different motivations
at play i think
well the example i always use is
the finder
right i think that's the entry or the
entry level for for people
you should also really be able to take
in your web browser take the items that
are
buttons or whatever that's on someone's
site and just rip it out and put it on
your desktop there's really no reason
you shouldn't be able to you should have
a system that allows you to do that
um
web browsers are complicated though i
would say i would start with something
simple like the finder because that is
the entry point for people when they're
using a operating system
right no we don't we don't have that we
don't have separate levels
so there's not you can't for example
lock a stack so that it's only readable
and you can't you know this hyper what
he's paying reference to is that
hypercard used to have authorship levels
uh one to five there was people who were
like readers and you couldn't open up a
button and edit a script or anything
and then there was five which was the
most
uh authoritative and you could basically
do anything but we don't we don't have
any restrictions like that no
yeah so the question is um
the gentleman here works with children
and he says that they are you know
actively using programs like minecraft
and roblox and they're being very
creative and dynamic with their
with their medium and what do i make of
that i think that the video game people
have been ahead of everybody else for a
very long time even in the way they make
the games
this is a highly interactive experience
for making games if you i don't know a
lot about making games but i've seen
people use unity it's fascinating
uh for people who do other kinds of
software development we're nowhere near
that
sitting here in our terminals
scratch is
i think scratch is wonderful
um
one of the things and this is also a
problem that some of the small talks
have currently is that
it doesn't look like the real thing an
advantage of hypercard in its prime
was that it looked exactly like the real
thing it was not different and i
remember from when i was younger and
maybe some of you have a similar
experience you want to make the real
thing you don't want some bootleg
copy
even today you know if you use like uh
gtk or qt or something you're like oh
it's not quite there's kind of looks
funny
and i think that actually goes a long
way
in terms of the i'm not super familiar
with a lot of the load glow code
solutions today
um but i think that certainly is a step
in the right direction
the question is is there important to
make a distinction between
web things and desktop things native
applications
um
that's a tough one in
if we're still in my ideal universe i
would throw away web browsers entirely
and just get re-get rid of the web i
think it is
is become a
too big of a pile of ideas
that are not well organized and i think
don't have good metaphors
not good metaphors there if there was a
good document metaphor it has jumped the
shark a long time ago
you know i i know that there's a lot of
push towards you know the web is the
operating system the reason we wrote
this in a web browser is because
you know i i was going to do it in a
small talk but it's a big ask to have
someone download a virtual machine when
they already have one running on their
computer
and that may sound like i did it out of
convenience but i'm doing it out of what
i think is uh a setback
that is a setback
yeah so the question is a lot of
programming is done in excel is that
different from this or is that a
springboard into something else
i love excel i love spreadsheets it's
definitely the most widely used
programming environment in the world as
far as i can tell
and
that that also has a very good
kinesthetic and visual metaphor for what
it's dealing with
and in fact one of the elementary parts
we were going to build in in the next
round if we ever got to it was going to
be a basic cheap part
that then you could map to other things
if you were
so inclined
yeah i don't know i'm not sure how much
else to say about that spreadsheets are
incredibly powerful and i
tend to not like
when
you hear some software engineers kind of
you know turning down their nose at what
regular people are doing
with spreadsheets
yes
so the question is about emacs emacs is
one of these highly malleable
environments what lessons would i learn
from emacs what would i take away from
that
um
this is my emacs
uh very highly customized emacs i i uh
go down that rabbit hole but the the
so
yes emacs is wonderful i love emacs it
doesn't have the layers
we need to have the layers i think a
real crucial part of this is the
metaphor layers that are self-consistent
and can be used to describe the ones
above them
that is how you peel back the onion
that's what we were thinking anyways
man there's a
the question is um
hyper card small talk
debatably and visual basic failed what
lessons can we take about
this whole concept
there's a really merely mouthed answer i
could give but maybe not so much of
computing should be tied to making
short-term profits
i think that'll go a long way
uh
you know this kind of thing is
inherently not profitable if you're
going to give someone the ability to
make a bunch of stuff who's going to
make money
now i think there's a there's several
reasons that apple
let hyper car die on the vine mostly
because they didn't know what to do with
it
they've done the same thing with
applescript
but apple's a trillion dollar company
they're a trillion dollar what are they
working on
shame on them they're making tv shows
and credit cards
what's going on they have all the
resources and all the intelligence
what's happening are they going to try
so i don't know i i think i think you
would have to
you know you have to make big changes
this is all about embedded in larger
social changes
yeah so the question is about even this
is working with the bread and butter
physical interfaces of classical
computing keyboard screens two
dimensions
and is that going to work for this kind
of thing going forward
i'm going to do
the
easy thing and i'm going to pass that on
to brett victor because i think dynamic
land is a really good exploration of
that
and his writing about the use of hands
on his website i think everybody should
read i think there's a whole kinesthetic
component to all this that's
vastly underrated
yeah um
yeah swift playgrounds on the
tablets
i mean if you want to learn programming
the way it's done today i think that's
what
seems fantastic to me
that's a great new way to learn
cuneiform as far as i'm concerned
right
so let me try to summarize that in the
in the for the stream
the question is allen k had the research
project 10 years ago at viewpoints which
was steps towards the future programming
nsf-funded
uh project and they had basically come
up with making a bunch of small dsls for
different layers of this part of the
thing and the question is would simple
talk be something like that or would it
be more like emacs where it's a pile of
of e-list well the first thing i want to
say before i answer that directly is
that the uh
the peg that we use for the scripting
language is omjs which comes directly
out of the work from steps and later
uh hark that was at y combinator so we
found that really useful so yeah we
read a lot of the steps papers and that
was like highly influential
what we were envisioning for
oh where am i here
hold on guys i have a navigator what we
were envisioning for uh simple talk was
that we were just really experimenting
only with one part
of this layer here
so it wasn't going to be a pile of
simple talk scripting language all the
way down there would be a different yeah
what you would maybe call a dsl for each
layer
so these actors there would be some
language in which you would configure
the actors and tell them how to
communicate with each other at the
bottom and then the ui would be
described in terms of them and so on and
and so forth
but you know we didn't know we didn't
get a chance to do any of that part of
it i think that that's a really rich
environment for experimenting with
things because then you know what works
and what doesn't when you're going
between these layers right yeah i think
that's very interesting
um
are we at time does anybody know do we
need to go
okay well thank you all if you have any
more questions i'll be around and you
can post them in the slack of course
so thank you for coming out
[Music]
you